merci Bernard bonne de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes allé de la Loire membre du groupe
les républicains on a plusieurs sujets à
aborder avec vous d'abord on commence
par la fin de vie puisque le Sénat remet
aujourd'hui un rapport d'information sur
la fin de vie qui sera examiné en
commission des affaires sociales à
laquelle vous appartenez est-ce qu'il
faut une nouvelle loi pour l'égaliser
l'aide active à mourir
on se pose justement de la question je
pense qu'il faut
améliorer la loi qui est une loi qui est
qui permet effectivement de faciliter
enfin d'aider en tout cas les personnes
à mourir dignement mais aujourd'hui la
loi Clécy n'est pas impliquée partout
parce que les soins palliatifs ne sont
pas mis en place dans toutes les
départements et je crois que c'est
certainement le point le plus important
à régler avant de mettre en place une
nouvelle loi donc c'est trop tôt parce
que la loi est annoncée pour avant le 21
septembre pour vous il faut pas faire
cette loi maintenant il faut d'abord
régler la question des soins palliatifs
effectivement il y a plus d'une
vingtaine départements où il y a pas de
son palliatifs aujourd'hui oui on n'a
pas fait d'évaluation encore de
l'application de
cette loi sur les soins palliatifs et je
pense qu'il ne faudrait d'abord mettre
en application ce qui avait été prévu
dans la première loi avant de créer une
autre et puis on sait toutes les
difficultés effectivement de mettre en
place une nouvelle loi avec des nouveaux
principes il y a une convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie qui s'est
prononcé en très grande majorité pour
une évolution de la loi et pour une aide
active à mourir qu'est-ce que vous leur
dites du coup elle s'est citoyens
je pense qu'il faut tenir compte
beaucoup en tout cas de la vie
des médecins et je crois effectivement
que les opinions très divergentes qu'on
voit aujourd'hui s'exprimer montre bien
toute la difficulté en tout cas pour
justement prendre une décision à ce
niveau d'une nouvelle loi qui
permettrait d'aller plus loin que ce qui
est aujourd'hui autorisé donc il faut
d'abord écouter les soignants qui
effectivement
qui sont au plus près des personnes
justement
dans cet état là et je crois qu'il faut
vraiment faire en sorte qu'on aille pas
trop loin en tout cas dans les nouvelles
possibilités même si dans d'autres pays
on les a mis en oeuvre depuis plusieurs
années justement est-ce que ça crée pas
une injustice sociale avec les Français
qui ont les moyens d'aller choisir leur
fin-vit dans d'autres pays et ceux qui
ne peuvent pas je crois pas que ce soit
une injustice sociale je pense que c'est
plus une
une difficulté au niveau de notre pays
parce que chacun réagit un peu
différemment mais dans notre pays de
prendre une décision aussi importante
que celle-là alors bien sûr on peut
aller dans d'autres pays je crois pas
que ce soit le côté financier qui soit
le plus important mais bon c'est comme
pour d'autres questions qui touchent à
la vie en général et toutes les
problèmes d'éthique je pense qu'il faut
quand même qu'on reste sur des positions
faire au niveau de la France et puis
qu'on puisse réfléchir beaucoup plus
avant avant de prendre des décisions
aussi importantes donc en allant
vraiment pas plus loin vous êtes opposé
à l'état à l'euthanasie j'imagine mais
même le suicide assisté pour vous c'est
pas envisagé pour le moment enfin notre
avis non maintenant il y a peut-être
d'autres formes qui peuvent aller un peu
plus loin que ce qui existe aujourd'hui
on va parler de l'audition que vous avez
faite audition de Jean-Christophe comte
c'est le Ministre des Solidarités sur le
projet de loi pleine emploi il arrive en
séance le 10 juillet et parmi les
propositions de ce projet de loi un
service public de la petite enfance et
vous en avez parlé hier avec le ministre
on voit ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Marion Vigreux
[Musique]
bonjour Marion bonjour Ariane bonjour
monsieur one et Marion va donc revenir
avec vous sur l'audition par la
commission des affaires sociales de
Jean-Christophe combiner des solidarités
de l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
l'objectif de cette audition c'était
d'entendre le ministre sur la stratégie
du gouvernement en matière de service
public à la petite enfance l'accueil des
jeunes enfants qui intègrera donc ce
projet de loi plein qui a profité de
cette audition pour rappeler comment la
question des modes de garde est un
parcours du combattant pour les parents
il l'a présenté une enquête réalisée par
Lipsos en avril 2023 et qui révèle que
pour 61% des parents interrogé la
recherche d'un mode d'accueil à
constituer un facteur de stress
important pour le ministre l'accueil du
jeûne enfant répond à quatre défis de
société et le premier c'est
effectivement le plein emploi et je vous
propose de l'écouter à ce sujet
on estime à 150 000 le nombre de parents
qui renoncent à un emploi faute de mode
d'accueil pour leur enfant et ensuite
parce que la petite enfance est un
secteur dynamique et qui va rester on y
compte aujourd'hui environ 600 000
professionnels et les défis sont
nombreux environ 10000 professionnels
font défaut aujourd'hui au sein des
crèches et 120 000 assistants maternels
pourraient cesser leur activité d'ici à
2030 et parmi les autres défis liés à
cet accueil il y a l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes se sont bien
souvent les mers qui sont pénalisés par
le déficit d'accueil en particulier les
mers isolés il y a aussi la question de
la lutte contre les inégalités de destin
c'est à dire comment dans les 1000
premiers jours du nouveau-né l'accès à
des temps de socialisation d'éveil et
nécessaire au bon développement de
l'enfant et puis enfin l'autre défi
c'est celui de la natalité les problèmes
liés à l'accueil du jeune enfant Fresnes
aujourd'hui cette natalité qui est en
baisse continue en France Bernard bonne
pensez-vous aussi que cet enjeu de
l'accueil utiliser transversale qu'on
réglera finalement plusieurs problèmes
en s'y attaquant
l'accueil des jeunes enfants a toujours
été un problème moi j'étais mère il y a
pas mal d'années c'était déjà un
problème une difficulté effectivement de
trouver pour les personnes qui
recherchaient des places de créer des
justement des crèches ou des Halles de
garderie qui permettaient aux femmes à
l'époque surtout de pouvoir travailler
d'être un peu plus libre aujourd'hui
effectivement on parle de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes et il est
vrai qu'il faudrait absolument mettre en
place un système qui permet autant aux
hommes qu'aux femmes de pouvoir
travailler en confiant leurs enfants
lorsqu'il le faut je crois aussi qu'il
faut et vous les dites pour permettre
une natalité un peu plus importante
donner plus de moyens on a parlé des
1000 jours les 1000 jours importants
d'un enfant lorsqu'il n'est de permettre
en tout cas d'avoir plus de moyens dans
la famille et à l'extérieur de la
famille de garder cet enfant dans
d'excellentes conditions il faut pas que
ce soit forcé il faudrait qu'on arrive à
trouver des solutions qui conviennent
aux parents qui leur permet de
travailler s'il le souhaite et qui
permettent aussi de rester en contact
plus longtemps avec leur enfant comme ce
qui peut se faire en Allemagne par
exemple comme ce qui se fait dans
d'autres pays notamment en Allemagne ou
dans des pays du Nord
et Marion parmi les premiers objectifs
du gouvernement il y a le développement
du nombre de solutions d'accueil oui
alors l'objectif il est tout d'abord de
100000 places nouvelles d'ici à 2027 et
de 2000 d'ici à 2030 haute priorité
c'est renforcer l'accompagnement des
communes parce que le gouvernement veut
vraiment que ce soit elle qui porte ce
service public elles seront aidées par
les CAF par un agent de la CAF par
département et puis l'autre enjeu c'est
vraiment l'attractivité de ces métiers
de la petite enfance qui sont délaissés
et parfois méconnues par les jeunes en
selon le ministre 10 000 postes on
rappelle ne sont pas pourvus et ça
demande aussi une revalorisation des
salaires un développement des formations
et ce sera tout le sujet du plan
d'urgence qui sera présenté en fin de
semaine par le ministre à Nancy pour
améliorer justement cette qualité
d'accueil des jeunes enfants et on voit
que l'attractivité des métiers de la
petite enfance finalement elle ressemble
à celle qui se pose sur les métiers de
la dépendance
surtout le médico-social on a des
difficultés effectivement d'attractivité
des métiers je crois que ce sont des
métiers difficiles qui sont pas assez
valorisés pas assez rémunérés il faut
absolument qu'il y a un effort
considérable dans dans tous les domaines
que des personnes handicapées de la
petite enfance de la protection de
l'enfance des personnes âgées de la
petite enfance bien entendu de chercher
tous les moyens qui pourraient permettre
effectivement d'avoir plus de personnes
plus de disponibilités à ce niveau et je
recherchais tout ce qui pourrait attirer
des personnes dans ces métiers par le
gouvernement dans les pistes qui ont été
présentées notamment hier quand on
pensait où il y a pas eu de pistes
présentées pour augmenter notre activité
il y a une stratégie effectivement de
communication ou autre mais je crois
qu'il faut vraiment se donner des moyens
au niveau de la rémunération d'abord et
puis chercher par la formation très
rapide de ces personnes très rapides
enfin non pas rapides au niveau de la
formation mais faire rapidement des
propositions au niveau de la formation
pour qu'elle soit facilité encouragé et
mise à disposition des jeunes le plus
tôt possible
marie en revanche la question du congé
parental n'apparaît pas dans ce projet
de loi oui mais le ministre a fait
savoir que des réflexions a été en cours
pour le réformer sa vision à lui de se
conger ce serait un congé qui soit plus
court qui soit mieux partagée entre les
parents et puis surtout mieux
endedemniser là aussi est-ce que à vos
yeux Bernard bonne ce n'est pas dans le
texte mais vous pensez que là aussi il y
a un sujet de débat qui qu'il faut
réformer ce congé qu'il n'est pas
satisfaisant
les 1000 premiers jours sans
certainement les plus importants au
niveau de l'enfance je me dis aussi en
tant que médecin je crois qu'il faut
absolument que c'est 1000 premiers jours
soit privilégiés pour l'enfant et pour
les parents si on donne au moyen les
moyens aux parents pour justement avoir
plus de possibilités pour garder leur
enfant ou pour le faire garder l'antenne
d'excellente conditions c'est
certainement très souhaitable donc il
faut revaloriser effectivement les
indemnisations il faut faire en sorte
que les parents puissent se libérer
beaucoup plus sans perdre les évolutions
au niveau du travail qu'il pourrait
avoir dans dans beaucoup de cas est-ce
que vous regrettez qu'il ne soit pas
dans le texte qui est envisagé par le
gouvernement je crois qu'il faut aller
quand même plus loin que si elle propose
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est 1000
premiers jours je reviens encore à ça
sans vraiment
un objectif
indispensable pour faire en sorte qu'on
est beaucoup moins de problèmes à la
suite avec des jeunes enfants
merci Marion merci à tout à l'heure pour
parler de la loi de programmation
militaire à un tout autre sujet ce sera
si effectivement dans le club à tout à
l'heure Marion on va parler d'un autre
sujet sur lequel vous travaillez c'est
la question de la dépendance des
personnes âgées Bernard bonne
Jean-Christophe qu'on mettait à votre
place hier le ministre il a confirmé
qu'il y aurait pas de grandes lois
dépendances durant ce quinquennat mais
un plan d'action est-ce que vous
regrettez qu'il n'y a pas de grande loi
qui avait été pourtant promise par
Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 et bien sûr
que je le regrette ça fait des années
qu'on nous promet cette loi grand âge
des années que tous les ans nous dit ça
sera bientôt on ne va y arriver et
aujourd'hui
on admet l'idée qu'il y en aura pas du
tout c'est
très très regrettable je crois qu'on a
pas mis les moyens on ne veut pas mettre
les moyens au niveau des personnes âgées
pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse les les
traiter dignement et je pense que c'est
parfaitement honteux alors
Jean-Christophe con mais le gouvernement
dit mais il y aura un plan d'action il y
aura des mesures qui vont être prises il
y en aura dans le budget 2024 il y en
aura d'autres qui sont prises dans
d'autres textes dont le texte sur le
bienvir qu'est-ce que vous attendez vous
de ce plan d'action est-ce que ça peut
être suffisant selon vous non bien sûr
je crois tout a été dit tout a été
[Musique]
prévu tout a été chiffré au niveau de ce
qu'il faudrait pour les personnes
dépendantes cet effet dans les rapports
parlementaires cet effet dans les
rapports de midi ou d'autres ça a été
fait au niveau de toutes les les ceux
qui s'occupent des personnes âgées tout
a été dit tout a été proposé on sait ce
qu'il faut faire par contre il faut la
volonté au niveau du gouvernement de les
moyens financiers pour aller justement
vers cette prise en charge de
l'indépendance dans de bonnes
branche pour vous c'était que des
paroles ah oui c'est une coquille
complètement vide moi je ne comprends
pas
oui il faudrait 10 milliards
pas du tout il faudrait dire
supplémentaire par rapport à ce qui
existe bien sûr si en comptabilise qui
est donné aujourd'hui il y a plus de 10
milliards il faudrait 10 milliards
supplémentaires on a mis des sommes
considérables au niveau du quoi qu'il en
coûte on met là je vois le président
Macron a dépense 11 ou 14 milliards en
quelques semaines là comme ça et on
n'est pas capable de mettre 10 milliards
de plus pour les personnes âgées je
trouve ça honteux qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait pour vous qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de ce plan d'action qu'elle
doit être la mesure principalement les
mesures principales il y a plusieurs
mesures bon on a parlé effectivement
d'avoir la gouvernance après la
clarifier ces gouvernance ensuite il
faut faire en
la responsabilisation entre les services
et l'État les services des départements
et voir qui décide qui décide au niveau
des personnes âgées qui décident au
niveau des établissements qui s'occupent
des personnes avec des départements
chefs de films voilà on clarifie des
choses et ça a été proposé avec des des
comités de pilotage effectivement dans
les départements mais le clarifier ça
c'est la première chose et puis mettre
en place des parcours de vie des
personnes âgées il faut absolument qu'on
puisse organiser dans chaque territoire
des parcours de vie entre le domicile le
maintien à domicile la prévention et
puis la possibilité pour les personnes
d'aller dans différentes structures qui
soient plus ou moins médicalisées mais
qui leur permet d'avoir un suivi et qui
ne les mettent pas en difficulté dès
qu'elle dès qu'elle perde un peu de leur
autonomie c'est ça qui manque et puis il
faut retrouver aussi là on en a parlé
tout à l'heure de l'attractivité des
métiers c'est très difficile on a
beaucoup parlé de l'affaire hors pa mais
l'affaire européen c'est c'est ce qui a
permis de montrer tout le manque qu'on
avait dans tous les établissements alors
c'est vrai qu'il y a des difficultés au
niveau des établissements lucratifs il
faut régler certains problèmes mais il y
a des difficultés dans toutes les étapes
privées ah non je dis pas ça du tout par
contre il faut qu'il y ait une égalité
de traitement entre les uns et les
autres ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui mais ce qu'il faut surtout
c'est essayer de trouver au niveau de
tous ces établissements un nombre de
personnes suffisant auprès de la
personne âgée dépendante qu'on puisse
continuer ce sont des métiers qui
n'attire plus aujourd'hui pourquoi ils
ne tire plus parce qu'ils sont
difficiles parce que souvent il y a un
turn-over qui est trop important parce
que les personnes ne sont pas assez
rémunérées je crois qu'il faut
revaloriser ces salaires beaucoup plus
qu'on a prévu parce que ces personnes
font un travail remarquable pénible mais
qui nécessite vraiment d'être accompagné
à tous les niveaux est-ce qu'il faut
aussi des mesures pour aider les
familles parce qu'aujourd'hui être dans
un état d'être dans une maison de
retraite ça coûte cher
alors on a parlé on avait fait des
rapports aussi sur le financement je
crois qu'il faut là aussi c'est là où on
demande effectivement les 10 milliards
supplémentaires mais il faut qu'on
puisse permettre à toutes les familles
dans toutes les n'importe quelle
condition d'aller dans des maisons qui
soient adaptées à l'état des personnes
et des personnes dépendantes et je pense
que là aussi il faut qu'il y ait une
aide peut-être une une on avait proposé
une assurance un peu obligatoire qui
serait
solidaire et qui permettrait à tout le
monde d'avoir en cas de dépendance les
moyens suffisants pour aller n'importe
où des mesures pour les aidants pour le
répit notamment des aidants est-ce que
vous attendez ça aussi du gouvernement
ça on l'avait prévu j'allais dire c'est
complémentaire une fois qu'on aura mis
en place ces premières mesures je pense
qu'après tout le reste suivra beaucoup
plus facilement il faut d'abord mettre
en place les moyens d'accueil et puis
après au niveau des aidants qui sont
très importants on pourra mettre des
mesures complémentaires après on va voir
la qualité dans votre département on va
parler des sénatoriales puisque votre
département fait partie de ceux qui sont
renouvelables mais vous ne serez pas
candidats où on va en parler tout de
suite on va Saint-Étienne retrouver
Alice Canivet rédactrice en chef à TL7
la télé locale de la loi et Alice elle a
deux questions pour vous on va écouter
d'abord la première
bonjour Bernard bonne nous sommes à
saint-genest-ler à quelques kilomètres
de Saint-Étienne dans la Loire un
département que vous connaissez par cœur
parce que vous l'avez présidé pendant
presque 10 ans alors voici ma question
quelles ont été vos principaux
accomplissements en tant que sénateur de
la Loire en utilisant vos compétences
d'élus locales alors au niveau c'est
vrai qu'au niveau vous l'avez rappelé
j'ai été président du Département
pendant une dizaine d'années j'étais
vice-président pendant pas mal d'années
aussi et j'ai continué à m'occuper
beaucoup de médico-social en essayant
d'améliorer toutes les prises en charge
à la fois des personnes âgées de
l'enfance et essayer de faire des
demandes une amélioration dans ce sens
là et bien entendu au niveau de des
territoires j'ai surtout cherché à
accompagner les communes dans toutes les
projets qu'elles avaient je pense que
c'était le plus important après il y a
toutes les obligations au niveau de
l'éducation des collèges des routes
qu'on a fait normalement et qu'on a
essayé de faire bien mais je crois que
le la principale action des départements
c'est même au niveau social et je crois
que c'est une compétence qui est
essentielle et qui nécessite qu'en s'y
consacre beaucoup une deuxième question
d'Alice hein toujours en rapport avec
les sénatoriales et la réalité le
département de la Loire compte 292
communes rurales et la ruralité
justement c'est une des thématiques
communes à toutes les listes candidates
au sénatorial dans la Loire c'est une
thématique donc très importante pourquoi
le pays le gouvernement a besoin des
villages en France
je crois qu'il faut absolument qu'il y
ait cette
cette volonté dans tous les départements
d'avoir à la fois une partie
urbaine et une partie rurale et la
complémentarité entre les deux est
essentielle je pense que on ne peut pas
avoir simplement une vie urbaine sans
avoir la possibilité effectivement de
vier la campagne et puis c'est un
équilibre ça équilibre au niveau de la
nature c'est un équilibre au niveau de
la vie c'est un équilibre à tous les
niveaux et il faut absolument justement
privilégier le cette complémentarité et
non pas essayer d'opposer l'un à l'autre
c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire en tout
cas dans la Loire qui est un département
semi rural parce qu'il y a quand même
des grandes villes mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de communes rurales et je pense
que le département est là pour justement
faciliter cette équilibre et c'est ce
qu'on a essayé de faire pendant de
nombreuses années et le gouvernement il
en fait assez pour la ruralité il y a un
plan ruralité qui a été présenté il y a
quelques jours est-ce que pour vous
c'est suffisant le gouvernement essaie
de certaines choses mais arrêtons de
recentraliser je crois qu'il faut
laisser au niveau des départements et
des régions le soin de faire cette
équilibre ibre entre la l'urma et le
rural et je pense que c'est pas au
gouvernement le gouvernement doit
laisser laisser des moyens au niveau des
collectivités pour justement faire
mettre en place cet équilibre et non pas
faire des lois ou mettre des décrets en
place qui qui n'ont pas besoin d'être
mis parce que on sait faire sur place
alors Alice a parlé des sénatoriales je
le disais vous avez fait le choix de ne
pas vous représenter vous pourquoi
je crois d'abord il y a un âge pour tout
je pense que un certain moment il faut
savoir s'arrêter j'ai été pendant très
longtemps au niveau du département
différents niveaux des collectivités
j'ai voulu essayer d'apporter à un peu
une contribution note notamment au
niveau du microsocial dans le niveau du
Sénat et je crois que maintenant il est
temps d'arrêter je pense qu'il y a des
jeunes qui sont prêts à prendre la suite
tant de d'excellentes conditions parce
que sans d'excellents candidats et puis
et puis je vous le redis un temps pour
tout oh regarde les sénateurs sortants
de la Loire la droite qui était divisée
il doit toujours être divisé a toujours
été divisé je crois que pour la première
fois au niveau de la droite la Loire
présentera une seule liste et c'est une
très bonne chose je crois qu'il faut
montrer une unité d'action et que les
personnes qui sont sur la même liste
vont pouvoir s'équilibrer au niveau des
commissions s'ils sont élus et
permettent d'apporter à la Loire plus
que ce qu'on a peut-être pu apporter
jusqu'à maintenant et c'est là l'intérêt
de cette plus en nombre de siège aussi
ah ben je l'espère je l'espère j'espère
au moins trois si c'est possible au
détriment du PC ou du PMA bon je veux
pas être devant là dedans mais je pense
que ce sera plus territoire
donc vous espérez trois sièges pour les
républiques qu'est-ce que vous retenez
vous de vos six années au Sénat
je retiens j'ai eu la chance d'être
nommé rapporteur du médico-social en
arrivant ce qui m'a donné avec la
majorité qu'on a au niveau du Sénat la
possibilité d'apporter une contribution
importante au niveau de tous les
rapports et au niveau du médico-social
puisque avec la majorité ça nous permet
d'avoir une certitude une certitude que
nos amendements nos projets de loi soit
acceptés
par contre effectivement je trouve que
le gouvernement ne tient pas assez
compte de du rôle du Sénat ne tient pas
assez con de ce que l'on peut apporter
et je trouve que y compris depuis un an
ou la donne a changé à l'Assemblée
depuis un an mais pas pas beaucoup ça a
changé en paroles mais pas un acte alors
qu'avant il y avait une sorte de mépris
et de rejet un peu de du parlementarisme
et notamment au niveau du Sénat et je
crois que c'était c'était très
regrettable alors c'est pour ça que je
pourrais regretter un peu ce que le
Sénat ne peut pas apporter mais moi j'ai
été très satisfait en tout cas euh de ce
qui m'a été confié en tant que
rapporteur et de pouvoir apporter soit
dans l'enfance soit au niveau des
personnes âgées une contribution qui
même si elle est modeste a toujours été
intéressantes pour moi si vous deviez
retenir un texte un rapport pendant ces
6 ans ça serait lequel ça serait celui
sur la protection de l'enfance c'est le
travail que j'ai fait avec Adrien taquet
avec qui on a très bien travaillé avec
l'Assemblée nationale également et on a
pu apporter quand même un plus et je
crois que c'est peut-être la pierre la
plus importante que j'ai pu apporter
dans dans ce travail de 6 ans est-ce que
vous allez continuer la politique vous
arrêtez de Sénat mais est-ce que vous
allez poursuivre votre engagement
politique non j'arrête la politique je
crois que là aussi il faut savoir dire
un certain âge on n'a pas besoin de
personne
âgées j'allais dire on peut apporter une
expérience dans certains domaines mais
je préférerais en tout cas continuer
dans le domaine médical et c'est
d'apporter bénévolement une aide à
différents niveaux mais dans un
anonymates total et voilà vous serez
retraité je serai de médecin retraités
qui essaiera d'apporter une contribution
là où là où je rentrerai utile merci
Bernard merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous pour la dernière fois du coup on
vous souhaite bonne continuation dans
votre vie et aussi beaucoup de petits
enfants
voilà et vous aurez du temps à leur
consacrer merci merci d'avoir été avec
nous dans 20 minutes dans le top des
territoires débat sur la loi de
programmation militaire dans le Sénat a
commencé l'examen hier un budget en
hausse mais nos armées ont-elles
suffisamment de moyens matériels et
humains ce sera le débat du club mais
d'abord on a quand même notre invité
politique c'est François-Xavier Bellamy
qui nous rejoint